- I'm Jeff Dodds, I'm
a Math Content Creator
here at Khan Academy.
I had a fixed mindset
for a really long time.
I was convinced that I was a math person,
and I was smart, and I
was just good at math.
And so I remember the first
time I really struggled
was I was taking a linear algebra course,
and the homework was not
required, it was optional.
The grade just came
from quizzes every week,
and a midterm and a final.
And I thought that if the
lectures were making sense
then I must understand it.
And so I was really frustrated
with my initially low scores,
and my brain started
like switching into this
really fixed mindset where
I would blame the teacher
because they must not be
preparing us well for the quizzes.
But then I started to
suspect, like oh gosh,
maybe I'm just not that smart.
Maybe I'm not good at math after all,
and I was just wrong all along.
But I took to like joining study groups
for students in the class who
were doing better than me,
and I thought just by
like being around them
that I could somehow like
soak up their smartness
and figure out the trick
that they had discovered.
And I was kind of surprised
that their key to success
was just getting together, and doing
the optional practice
problems, and talking them out,
and people were vulnerable
and asking questions
and saying I don't understand this,
can someone help me out with this?
And it was the first time
where it kinda clicked for me
that oh, optional practice,
I don't have to do it
just because it's for a grade,
I can do it to learn and grow,
and I have to give up
the idea that I'm smart
and understand this on my own,
and work with other people
to ask them questions
when I was getting stuck with something.
Or to help someone when they needed it.
To help myself grow and the grades would
take care of themselves from there.
I had to give up that
sense of, oh I'm smart
and I can get this all on my own.
It really changed the way
I approached my coursework,
not just in math, but
in everything past that
where I kind of realized
the importance of practice
and asking questions, and
being vulnerable enough to say,
I don't understand this,
and I need some help.
Being able to admit that to
myself and to other people
that I do not understand this,
and you understand a lot better than me,
so I would like your help please.
That was really big for me,
and that's still really important.
When I was a teacher, or in my job today
where I think, you know
maybe there's a better way
to teach this concept, and I
can reach out to other people
and look at what they do.
It's okay to not be the master
because we're all students,
we're all still growing,
and everyone has room for
improvement in some way.
And if everyone just kind of
quietly works on their own,
then that's not gonna
produce the best outcomes
we can possibly get because
there's usually some area
we need help with, and
there's someone out there
who's happy to help you so why not?
Why not go take advantage of that?